Let's talk about jobs. We are starting to see
better and better jobs numbers as coronavirus
cases have been declining, hospitalizations have
been declining. Deaths, while still tragically
high, are also declining. And hopefully
this is going to continue. In February,
nonfarm payrolls went up three hundred and seventy
nine thousand, even though the expectation was
only two hundred and ten thousand. So the real
numbers exceeding the expectations by about 50
percent more. In fact, the unemployment rate was
expected to be six point three percent. It came in
lower at six point two percent. And this is, of
course, just the start. There's a huge way to go
to recover from this pandemic. The pandemic
is nowhere near over 2000 people a day,
are still dying every day in the United States,
although we're starting to point to below those
numbers. But this is still something. Now, let's
do the normal disclaimers on the show. If you're
a new viewer or a new listener, I don't play
these Republican Democrat games with jobs numbers
and with the unemployment rate. I know that
a lot of shows they do this with gas prices.
They do this with debt and deficit. They do this
with unemployment numbers and jobs numbers. This
is not the show if you're looking for that
garbage. First of all, this has very little to
do with Joe Biden so far. Joe Biden is rolling out
vaccines much faster than Donald Trump was. That's
good. And that is starting to help cases go down
that has the effect of helping businesses to open,
but that moves really, really slowly. This is
not really about Joe Biden right now. This is a
result of broader economic circumstances, the
pandemic. And it has little to do with Biden
nor Trump, although for sure, had we had a real
adult response to the pandemic from the federal
government starting a year ago when it was Trump,
we never would have lost as many jobs as we lost.
And of course, we never would have lost as many
people as we tragically lost. But we've talked
about this many times before. And when we talk
about jobs numbers and administrations, second,
lots of people play this game of, oh, David,
you're talking about the U3 when it's convenient,
but you should really be talking about the you
six. I hate to even have to do this again, but
as a reminder, there are many unemployment rates
when you hear on the news the unemployment rate,
they are almost always talking about what's called
the U3. There is another unemployment rate called
the you six. The you six includes the people that
we talk about when we say six point two percent
are unemployed. But you add to that discouraged
workers. In other words, those who have not found
a job want one but are discouraged. They're not
even looking anymore. And you add in people who
are working part time but would rather be working
full time. They're only part time because they
can't find a full time job. And people love to
play games when the U3 goes down. But you want to
criticize the president, you say, well, let's look
at the you six, which is always higher right now.
Over the last month, the U.S. six is unchanged.
It's at eleven point one. There's no reason to
hide that. Again, this is not really a story
about Joe Biden anyway. This is a story about
the reality of the pandemic. I know lots of shows
love to mess with this stuff. We don't do that.
The hospitality industry is still three and a
half million jobs short of where it was a year
ago before the pandemic exploded. And if you
look at total employment, we have a long way
to go. There were more than one hundred and
fifty two million jobs before the pandemic.
There are now one hundred and forty three million.
We are nine million jobs short of the pre pandemic
numbers, despite having more people living in
the United States than we did a year ago. Now,
another attack on these numbers that's meant to
hurt Joe Biden is people saying, well, but David,
a lot of these new jobs are part time jobs. That's
true. And there are some unique circumstances
right now that explain that lots of businesses are
slowly reopening businesses that have been closed
or places that have been reduced, for example, to
a restaurant that's takeout only that is going to
start going in the direction of opening back up.
A lot of these businesses are bringing people back
in for just a few days per week. And hopefully, if
all goes well, if we continue to do the things we
have to do, many of those part time jobs will turn
to full time jobs as things continue to recover.
This is 90 percent about the reality of the
situation, not about Trump or Biden per say,
with the very important caveat that if Trump
had managed this well, it never would have
gotten as bad as it got. So the take away is slow
improvements. The better vaccination rollout goes
and the more people resist the urge to just
open everything wide open and go crazy,
the more quickly these numbers are going to be
able to recover. If things go perfectly, I mean,
listen, there's different estimates. If things go
perfectly, you could see the bulk of the recovery
happen during this calendar year. Some industries
are, even if everything goes as well as possible,
will not be fully recovered this year regardless.
And travel. Some estimates say travel won't fully
recover until summer of twenty, twenty two or
even later. I think, you know, things change so
quickly that any predictions going so far out are
of limited value. But the point is, we still have
a long road ahead of us and it's made longer by
people like the ones I'm going to talk about next.